Transcriber: Widad Y
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
(تصفيق)
من جبال القدس  بدأت الرحلة
جسمي معي غير أن الروح عندكم
فالجسم في غربة
والروح في وطن
فليعجب الناس مني
أن لي بدنا لا روح فيه
ولي روحا بلا بدن
مليون وأربعمية ألف فلسطيني
هجّروا من بلادهم
تركوا أحبابهم
وكسروا فخار ذكرياتهم
تركوا أرواحهم ضايعة بين أشجار الزيتون
والبيوت المهدمة
على أمل أن يرجعوا لها
وأخي أحمد، كان يدرس عن هذه القرى
والبلدات الفلسطينية بالمدرسة
لفتت انتباهه قرية لفتا
رجع عالبيت،
حكالي عنها بشغف وبطريقة حلوة
ناقشنا وتحاورنا
وقررنا أن نزور هذه القرية
الشامخة والصامدة على جبال القدس
وبعد محاولات كثيرة،
حصلنا على تصريح للدخول لهذه القرية
لكن للأسف، علي كان يعاني من ألم شديد
في قدمه فلم يستطع القدوم
لكني ذهبت وبدأت أصور الفيديوهات بالموبايل
صورت رائحتها
رائحة عشبها وترابها
ورائحة بيوتها القديمة
رجع أحمد عالبيت
وأراني الصور والفيديوهات
انصدمت
وضعنا خارطة فلسطين أمامنا
وبدأنا نعد القرى
قرية قرية
وجدنا ثلاثمية وخمسة وثلاثين قرية
فلسطينية مهجرة
عدنا لنعمل على فيديو لفتا
كتبنا النص
وسجلناه وأنتجناه ونشرناه
وبعدها بأيام أجتنا فكرة
إنا نصور الأماكن التراثية الجميلة
في فلسطين
كان السؤال: كيف نصور؟
كيف نذهب وكيف نرجع وأين سننشر؟
طبعا ونحنا صغار كنا نعشق التصوير
وعمل الفيديوهات
بس بطريقة بسيطة
وبفيديو لفتا، أصبح لزام علينا الاحتراف
تعلمنا لوحدنا وحضرنا محاضرات “اونلاين”
لحد ما صرنا قادرين على صناعة محتوى قوي
ومفيد
يناسب كل الأعمار التي ستشاهدنا
ولكي نبدأ في فيديوهاتنا
قررنا أن نتعلم فن الإلقاء ومواجهة الكاميرا
كيف تكون إطلالتنا رائعة
وكيف نوصل فكرة معينة للمشاهد
من خلال لغة الجسد
وبعد التدريبات المكثفة
والأيام الطويلة من العمل المستمر
حققنا هذا الإنجاز
وأصبحنا قادرين على عمل فيديو احترافي
يوصل فكرة معينة للمشاهد
عملنا كثيرا من المقابلات مع المحطات
الدولية والمحلية
انطلقنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
شاهدنا 35 ألف شخص
كنا عيون لهؤلاء الناس
من ولد في فلسطين أو خارجها
وصلتنا رسائل كثيرة
حفزتنا
ورفعت من ثقتنا بانفسنا
شجعتنا أن نستمر
ونطور هذه المبادرة الجميلة
أهمها
رسالة الأسير أسامة الأشقر
بعد ما سمعنا من داخل سجون الاحتلال
على راديو أجيال
حكا لنا
هذه فلسطين يا علي
هذه فلسطين يا أحمد
أنتم أعلام فلسطين بالمستقبل
أنتم فلسطين بحبها وشوقها للحياة
أنتم فلسطين بحبها للإبداع والريادة
وعملنا 85 فيديو
لكل فيديو قصة وحكاية
نحنا نعرف أن مشوارنا طويل
وأنه يوجد 535 قرية فلسطينية مهجرة
مع أن إمكانياتنا بسيطة
بدأنا بتلفون وستاند صغير
واليوم وصلنا لشيء جميل
قادرين أن نسوق لفكرتنا
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وقادرين على تحقيق حلمنا
بأن نكون صناع محتوى فلسطيني
مبادرتنا
ما صنعتها آلة
صنعتها شخصين فلسطينيين
خلال عامين من العمل المستمر
نحلم بالمستقبل
أن نعمل رحلة افتراضية
يدخل من خلالها المشاهد بتقنية 3D على قريته
يوقف عند النبعة
يشتري الصبار والتين والزيتون من
على أشجار قريته
بس حلمنا لا بتوقف هنا
نحن نحب بالمستقبل
أن نزور جميع الأماكن في فلسطين
ونوثقها بعدستنا الصغيرة
ونوصل إلى قطاع غزة
ونوثقه ونوثق الأماكن الجميلة فيه
نحنانحب مستقبلا
أن نترجم فيديوهاتنا لعدة لغات
لكي تصل لكل العالم
وتوصل رسالتنا لأكبر عدد من الناس
وبالنهاية أريد أن أحكي لكم رسالة
احلموا، وحاولوا تحققوا أحلامكم
عملنا 85 فيديو
وحققنا جزء من حلمنا وحلم متابعينا
ونطمح للأكثر في المستقبل
شكرا إلكم
(تصفيق)